Hi, I'm Katie Roney.
On behalf of Expert Village, we are talking about how to have a successful interview.
Through the course of your interview, write things down on your resume,...
...take notes maybe make a little list at the bottom or on the back of action items.
Things that you and the potential employer are discussing such as,...
..."Will they let you know what the benefits are?"
Are they gonna get back to you on some piece of information?
Take all of these down.
At the very end of the interview, you can flip back to it and say,...
..."Okay, just to follow up I want to make sure that we're on the same page."
And it's fun to do this. As a candidate, it lets them know that...
...you're summarizing, that you were listening, you're participating in the interview.
So, go over anything that you discussed previously and make sure you ask them,...
..."What are the next steps?
Are you gonna call me or should I give you a call in the next couple of days?"
Kinda feel them out and they'll probably let you know.
That creates a sense of urgency on their part...
...and they'll know that you're interested and ready to come back.
Phil, is there anything else that you'll go over?
I don't think so. I think you covered it all.
No questions or...
No, I don't think so.
Okay, is there anything that you wanted to discuss at all?
I think you covered everything.
Okay, well that's good. Hopefully I answered all your questions.
Okay, that was not good.
Not to me. His body language, his response was,...
"I actually don't care enough to ask you any questions...
...and I'm really just ready to get out of here."
So, be prepared and have your follow-up list.